des civils pris au piège dans les
entrailles du complexe métallurgique
désosse talent dernier bastion de
résistance de marioupol le corridor
humanitaire qui devaient être mises en
place samedi a été annulé en début
d'après midi en attendant les soldats
ukrainien du bataillon 1,9 apportent des
vivres à ces familles bonjour je vous ai
apporté des sucreries
respirer l'air frais aux dames
n'imaginez pas le bonheur que c'est de
manger quelque chose et de boire un bon
année à roger schall certains de ces
civils vie sous terre depuis presque
deux mois que je suis ici dans l'usiné
postale dans l'abri anti bombes avec ma
famille depuis le 25 février
nous avons besoin d'être évacués de
cette usine et nous demandons des
garanties de sécurité
le corridor humanitaire devait emmener
les résidents vers la ville de zappos
budget à 200 km au nord ouest
un nouvel échec qui est 20 combos russe
qui aurait dispersé les habitants
tentant de fuir
au delà des civils le président
ukrainien veut également permettre à
certains soldats de sortir du complexe
aux obstacles il s'est dit prêt à les
échanger contre des prisonniers russes